Five things that people use, I tried to find
them, they mess up our ozone and I have resigned
them...to the land of Mordor.
Where the shadows lie.
Lord of the Rings.
No?
That’s fine.
Hey everyone, welcome back to DNews, I’m
Matt Lieberman.
By now, everyone knows that our ozone is depleting,
and that things like cars and factories are
to blame.
Now we’ve made many solid advances on that
front, from hybrid and electric cars, to the
increased use of solar energy, but have we
thought of everything?
I feel like we’re forgetting something,
or, for that matter, several things that contribute
to the continued depletion of our precious
atmosphere.
Here are five products that need a serious
eco-upgrade.
For example, over 50 million Americans use
gas-powered lawn mowers on a weekly basis,
contributing 5% of the United States’ air
pollution alone according to People Powered
Machines.
Mowers seem small, but running a lawnmower
for one hour is the equivalent of running
11 cars for an hour simultaneously.
Not to mention that in re-fueling our lawn-munching
mowers, we spill on average 17 million gallons
of fuel per year.
This fuel evaporates into the air and has
the potential to form smog.
In closing, turn off the engine and find an
electric alternative!
And while we’re on the subject of lawn care,
can we talk about leaf blowers?
Besides causing noise pollution of the loudest
degree, they also contribute to air pollution
in a big way.
This is due to the widely used two-stroke
engine system.
In a 2011 study, car experts at Edmunds found
that “a consumer-grade leafblower emitted
more pollutants than a 6,200 pound 2011 Ford
F-150 SVT Raptor”.
In the test, they determined that a two-stroke
leafblower spat out almost 299 times the amount
of hydrocarbons as a pick-up truck.
Can we crack a window, please?
Actually, don’t, the air conditioning’s
on.
Actually, you know what?, shut it off and
open that window.
Air conditioners are also a big culprit here,
so much so that the EPA discussed their environmental
impact in their paper Good Up High, Bad Down
Low.
The chlorofluorocarbons, or CFCs, that they
emit cause a build-up of ozone in our lower
atmosphere.
Now we want ozone way up there, but down here,
it translates to smog, smog, smog.
Another household pollutant emitter is personal
generators, which are often used in non-emergency
conditions.
Generators emit nitrogen oxide, another creator
of lower-atmospheric ozone.
Unless we can regulate their use, we’re
going to have a whole mess of trouble on our
hands anytime people feel like going off the
grid.
And finally, I want to talk about lighters.
You know, the bics that you flick?
Whether you smoke or are just a big time candle
fan, you should know that lighters emit about
237 milligrams of carbon dioxide per minute.
To put that in perspective, if 1000 people
did a minute-long lighter salute at their
favorite concert, they’d release 1.2 kilograms
of carbon dioxide all at once.
Now your average power plant produces 12,200
kg of CO2 in that same time.
So imagine if that 1000 person salute happened
at 100 different concerts at once.
We’re looking at a power plant’s worth
of pollutants.
Let’s not and say we did, hmm?
Suggested questions: Anything I missed?
Are you gonna think twice before firing up
these things?
Let us know in the comments below and [push
to a related SourceFed video if there is one].
And don’t forget to hit that subscribe button
for more DNews every day.